gallop just released a poll of their
most admired people or of Americans most
admired people of 2013 so of course they
had to split this by sex because if you
put men in the women on a list together
god only knows what would happen so the
most admired man our president barack
obama about number two is kinda
interesting george bush at four percent
of these numbers are all pretty low
because they're just walking around
asking people who do you admire so it's
just like the same names that get popped
up the Pope Bill Clinton Bill Gates
Clint Eastwood Ron Paul Ted Cruz Romney
so it's all over the place politically
and then let's take a look at the women
Hillary at fifteen percent that's the
big one over a kind of downs i guess the
failure of own has taken its toll on her
michelle obama sarah palin condi Angela
Merkel Angelina Jolie so it's pretty
light on on celebrities like that um but
the women for women of color in that and
only one man of color in the hall and if
you noticed that interesting what do you
think that means um I think that uh I
don't I guess white guys are cooler with
dark women that's what that doesn't go
the other way Little John I know I I
have it I definitely have it yeah oh
yeah my wife's honor percent Mexican so
I like the dark skin there what do you
feel that this admiration list you
admire all these people is there someone
glaringly omitted from that list i i i i
find this list comical and i find it
comical because it's basically uh just a
list of whoever's the most well-known it
right it is not really a list of people
that you admire and the fact that sarah
palin is on this wiki with five percent
of the vote just moist oh yeah just
makes the whole thing useless and
completely lacking in any kind of
credibility whatsoever Wow stevo
sticking it to the gallup people that's
right sarah palin is just a world-class
idiot with virtually no redeeming value
whatsoever and whether you're
conservative or progressive there's no
reason to like her at all she is a
bumbling idiot an opportunist a quitter
she's done nothing with herself except
she's a she's a Fame [ __ ] that's it
yeah
why would you admire that this is
unbelievable so when I was in high
school high school I had two of the
books that were assigned one was the
brave new world by aldous huxley and the
other one was George Orwell's 1984 so do
these people who like Sarah Palin do
they not read those books in high school
are they not assign those things do they
not have the same experience do they not
watch mr. Smith goes to Washington do
they not understand how the rich and the
corporations control everything and
pervert democracy on a daily basis do
they not understand that well I think I
think if I could jump into the mind of
Sarah Palin a quarter for a second okay
they see her as the fighter against the
big government of 1984 you know they see
her as this anti-establishment really
big here that is cuz she's fighting
bears and you know doing all that stuff
so they see her as the the fighter
against that I think what does that make
any sense is it wrong p by law Steve
there hey he's owned out it's wrong for
us to say that the people who support
her are ignorant and dumb and yet they
lack the ability to decipher and see
through things whether you have the
ignorant dumb support Sarah Palin yeah
haha how could you not I mean I mean you
and look I don't I don't even mean that
at you know to offend those out there
who supports era para I'm just saying
you really need to like open your mind
Reid has my critical thinking because
she is not on your side he is on her own
side she is she's a terrible person she
couldn't be more serious that's a thing
of them you can't see through a sarah
palin then you know i have to make a
judgment call and say you're not on the
same intellectual level that i am and
but yet your vote counts just as much as
mine which is wrong that's a scary that
is a scary thought yes is there anyone
that you admire and wasn't on there at
all I guess somebody look that we talked
about earlier Edward Snowden probably
maybe Bradley Manning or chelsea manning
anyone else that I would say you know
people are gonna say I'm brown-nosing
but I'm gonna say Jen Kyogre well now
that you brought it up try to give my
show back it's all of you but you know
what okay look Jack so Jake and I we go
really
far back so it's hard for me to see him
as a celebrity the way other people see
him or anything like that but he is a
very admirable admirable person because
I know intimately the sacrifices that
he's made financial sacrifices and and
you know personal freedom sacrifices
that he's made to to do what he does and
to bring you know voices like yours and
yours to the forefront and try to do
something to change our society for the
better and our media for the better and
a democracy for the map for the better